the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu so today we're going to have
the final presentations from the student
projects so they did a lot of our work
some of them are still working upstairs
and we'll come down just in time
presentations for just a few a few
slides and on format and how the judging
will happen so each end will have 15
minutes during which tell us about the
little project and to give us a little
demo we have at least 2 PlayStation 3's
will be set up by the end of the class
one will have audio the other will have
video and at least two teams will use
them the others will SSH in and show you
their programs running on the
PlayStation 3's that we have upstairs on
the network one of the things that
they'll be graded on web scored on its
performance some of the things we'll do
after classes performance profiling to
try to understand how much scalability
you were able to achieve using one hour
officer vs two versus three all the way
up to six so we'll do is we'll set up
some time with the TAS to do to
profiling after class and you can update
your source code up until 9am so we'll
do we can you'll show us kind of your
profile and then we can rerun that at
nine a.m. saturday morning and sort of
give you updated scores to to change
your grades if it sounded great there
are six scoring categories performance
and this performance those first
performance category is essentially what
your performance metric is you're going
to define
tell us how well you did project scope
this is essentially measure because of
each of different projects for different
you pick your own projects will try to
get an understanding for how much you
try to cover your project what you
actually did achieve so will hopefully
do this a good idea of that completeness
you know how robust is your code how
much did you actually achieve relative
to what you wanted to do are there data
races is your code reproducible with
every run presentation and demo so we're
a couple of two just because there are
different ways people will be doing a
demo so you can't earn points in
different categories really good
presentation but if devil may not be so
fluffy we'll take that into account and
that's a form of scalability which will
do offline so each one of these
categories 4 on 10 point basis from one
to 10 10 being really good and for a
total of sixty points so for our judging
panel fortunately we couldn't get
virtual saman to fully work system arms
with us on the phone we have michael
gordon buildings to graduate students in
some orange group we have myself
professor steve ward from MIT and
professor wang kai wang who is visiting
from national university of singapore
during the sabbatical year here student
presentations will dynamically reorder
these based on who is available and who
is ready to go this is a rough ordering
that was picked randomly so if MOOC is
here it'll go first and then I see the
Linea Alba prac so they'll go after that
the ray tracing team is still in my
office working so we might have to
welcome them software your team is here
yep speech is here backgammon yep those
guys were already having breakfast
they're like not a clock the seventh
team modular dynamics simulator
unfortunately they're not here that that
team is not physically in Boston so
they'll present tomorrow morning
that will not be considered as kick
competitors in the competition there is
a countdown clock bill is running his
laptop can you see it directly in front
of you it'll start at 15 minutes and
every minute it will take down 14 13 all
the way down to zero and you can go into
negative times but we'll start
subtracting points so before you run
over more important to you can you start
the moving okay so try to keep under at
a time with what about westin there are
questions we can take those after the
presentation because a short question
yeah let's leave all questions until
after three mutations that unless
there's something pressing i'll try to
moderate okay so if we're ready to start
young